[موسيقى]
هذه سيارة
يمكنك القول إن أوكتافيا عبر رينو
مسؤولة عن جزء كبير من تلك
الصورة الحديثة التي نحتت بها مدينة بنما ،
لقد صنعت تلك السيارة هناك في المنتصف
التي كان يبنيها حرفيًا
لعقود من الزمن.  مطور عقارات ،
ما رأيك عندما تنظر
إليه في الأفق ، أعتقد أن هذا على
الرغم من أنني مواطن بنمي أعيش هنا
يثير إعجابي برؤية الأفق ، فهذا يعني
أنه انعكاس للازدهار هو
انعكاس للثقة التي أتعلمها
أنه على الرغم من كل شيء عانته هذه المدينة
عبر التاريخ ، إلا أن هناك
إحساسًا عميقًا بالولاء هنا ، ومن
الفخر أن النمو هنا مقبول ،
كل شيء بعد نورييغا كل دييجو نورييغا
هذا الاسم مرة أخرى ما كان يشبه العيش
هنا مشروب مضغ لا في هذا الوقت
لم يكن الأمر سيئًا حتى انفصل عن
الولايات المتحدة ، كان الاقتصاد في الواقع
كما تعلمون أن هذا يتسارع
بالتباطؤ باستمرار ، ثم مع
الغزو الأمريكي جاء
الصيف أطلق عليه اسم التحرير.
في الواقع ، ازدهرت بنما مرة أخرى إلى ما
هي عليه اليوم ، فأنت تعلم بالطبع أن العديد
من مواطنيك لا يرون بهذه
الطريقة ، ربما هناك بعض الوطنيين الذين
لا يريدون التعرف عليها ولكن هذه
حقيقة مطلقة أن رؤية
الولايات المتحدة  أعطت الدول بنما
ختمًا جيدًا للتدبير المنزلي يجعلنا واحدة من
أكثر الأماكن أمانًا في العالم ، ما
كان من شأنه أن يكون للفراعنة من بقية
دول أمريكا اللاتينية التي
تتحول في الوقت الحاضر إلى مواقف مروعة
، فلنتحدث عن فكرة
المظلة الأمريكية هذه إذا كان الأمريكيون هم من
لم نكن هنا ، لكانت بنما
على ما هي عليه اليوم ، ولهذا السبب
لدينا الكثير من الأجانب الذين يأتون للعيش
في بنما للقيام بأعمال تجارية في بنما ،
يصبح الصوديوم مواطنين
في بنما
بطريقة ما ، هناك سحر هنا
لا يفعله الناس '  لا اريد ان اعيش
لك